اعلن قائد القوات البحريه في الجيش
الايراني شهرام ايراني عن ادخال تجهيزات
عسكريه ودفاعيه حديثه للجيش بينها صواريخ
ذكيه ومسيرات ومروحيات وقال ان مدى
الصواريخ الذكيه يصل الى اكثر من 1000 ر
وقد تم تركيبها على السفن الحربيه
المستقره في ميناء كنارك في محافظه سيستان
وبلوشستان جنوب شرقي البلاد واشار القائد
الايراني الى ان تلك التجهيزات جميعها
محليه الصنع ويمكن ان تعزز قوه البحريه
الايرانيه في مجال الدفاع والقتال
البحر من طهران ينضم الينا الان مدير مكتب
الجزيره عبد القادر فايز عبد القادر ارحب
بك ماذا عن هذه التعزيزات اذا للقوات
البحريه الايرانيه ماذا تعني هذه
الخطوه تعني سفيان بان ايران تستشعر خطر
ما ق من منطقه ما لذلك هي تقوم على الاقل
وفق تصريحات العسكر هنا بتدعيم هذه الجبهه
جبهه القوات البحريه لماذا هناك انطباع
ربما لدى ايران منذ سنوات بان هذه الجبهه
هي الجبهه التي تشكل ربما الجبهه الاساس
عندما تتحدث عن اي تهديدات قادمه تحديدا
من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بالدرجه
الاولى اسرائيل بالدرجه الثانيه واي
تحالفات في هذه المنطقه بالمعنى الغربي
بالدرجه الثالثه لذلك هذا الموضوع يزداد
بشده حقيقه على وقع الحرب الاسرائيليه
الجاريه في قطاع غزه كل الكلام القادم من
البحر الاحمر من باب المندب من واشنطن حول
تحالف دولي في هذه المنطقه الاتهامات
الاسرائيليه لايران بانها تستهدف السفن
القادمه في الممرات البحريه الدوليه عبر
مسيرات كل هذا الكلام ربما يعطي انطباع
لدى ايران بانها هذه الجبهه باتت جبهه
ساخنه وبانها تتوقع تصعيد ما قادم من هذه
الجبهه خاصه وبان هناك كلام حقيقه سفيان
قادم من بريطانيا قبل يومين الى الان
يطالب بعمليات ردع مباشره يران
كذلك تتحدث بالمعنى السياسي بانها غير
معنيه في التصعيد وبان الموقف الامريكي في
المنطقه تحديدا مما يجري في قطاع غزه يعقد
الاوضاع بشكل كبير حقيقه وفق التوصيف
الايراني وتقول ايضا بان ما يجري في
الممرات المائيه
ربما يوجه رسائل مباشره لايران وبان ايران
معنيه بالتعاطي مع هذه القضيه لذلك اليوم
تتحدث عن صواريخ جديده الى البحريه
الايرانيه وكذلك تج تجهيزات اخرى ولكن
سفيان ل نشير الى نقطه مهمه ما جرى اليوم
هو تدعيم للقوات البحريه في الجيش
الايراني ولكن نحن نعلم تماما بان القوى
الضاربه عندما نتحدث عن القوات البحريه في
ايران هي بيد الحرس الثوري الايراني
بالدرجه الاولى وتحديدا في المياه
الخليجيه وصولا الى المحيط الهندي وربما
وصولا الى السفن الحربيه التي تجوب البحار
وتحديدا في البحر الاحمر وباب المندب لكن
في المجمل سفيان يمكن ان نقول بان ايران
تتحرك على وقع ما يجري في المنطقه على
واقع الموقف الامريكي الموقف الغربي وكذلك
التهديدات الاسرائيليه يران وواضح بان
ايران تتحرك عسكريا وفق هذا ال الموضوع
ولكن في السياسه هي تقول بشكل مباشر
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه بانها غير
معنيه بالتصعيد ولكن ترى الحل بان بان
يكون تغيير ولو بسيط في الموقف الامريكي
الداعم بشكل كبير وبسقف مرتفع لاسرائيل
وما تقوم به في قطاع غزه ننوي له هذا
العاجل بحسب مسؤول ايراني للجزيره قلنا
لواشنطن صراحه اننا لسنا اطفائي حرائق ولا
نصدر اوامر
لحلفائه في محور المقاومه هل من تعليق
لديك عبد القادر بشان هذا التصريح لمسؤول
ايراني
نعم سفيان قبل قليل كنا نتحدث الى هذا
المسؤول الايراني الذي قال بشكل واضح بانه
لا يمكن لاسرائيل ان تتوقع امن واستقرار
اقليميين في هذه المنطقه بينما ترتكب
المجازر بحسب التوصيف الايراني والاباده
الجماعيه في غزه ويقول بان الحلفاء في
المنطقه تحديدا انصار الله في اليمن وكذلك
حزب الله في لبنان لا يتلقون اوامر من
ايران بشكل بشكل مباشر لما يقوم به وبان
القرارات مستقله والسياده واضحه لدى هذا
المحور الذي يتحرك على وقع ما يجري في غزه
وهذا التصريح الذي اشرت له سفيان قال لنا
المسؤول الايراني بان ايران ابلغت امريكا
بشكل مباشر بانها لن تلعب دور اطفائي
الحرائق في هذه المنطقه وقال صراحه بان
هذه الحرائق جاءت بمعطيات اسرائيليه
بالدرجه الاولى وبان الموقف الامريكي
الداعم لاسرائيل في اشعال هذه الحرائق
اكثر واك اكثر بالمعنى الاقليمي وبان
الطلب الامريكي من طهران بان تلعب هذا
الدور وبحسب التوصيف الايراني هو طلب غير
منطقي وغير واقعي وبانه يجب على الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ان تغير من الموقف
الامريكي الداعم بسقف مرتفع وفق التوصيف
الايراني لما يجري في قطاع غزه الواضح
سفيان بان ايران تتحرك على وقع ما يجري في
الاقليم وتحديدا انطلاقا من قطاع غزه
ونشير بان المسؤول الايراني عندما سالناه
عن
التحالف الذي تتحدث عنه امريكا في باب
المندب قال صراحه بان العلاقات مع الدول
الخليجيه جيده ومستقره وبان هذا الحديث
الامريكي وهذا الموقف الامريكي هو من يعقد
الاوضاع وهو من سيزيد التصعيد اكثر في هذه
المنطقه بحسب توصيف هذا المسؤول الايراني
الذي تحدث للجزيره قبل قليل مدير مكتب
الجزيره عبد القادر فايز من طهران شكرا
جزيلا لك